une journée ensoleillée pour les
passionnés du vélo la Fédération
française de cyclotourisme organisait ce
samedi 20 mai à La Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet des événements à destination
des jeunes le critérium national 2023
proposé au 135 sportif
âgé de 13 à 18 ans de ce défi autour de
différentes compétitions ou vers au
licencier les écoles françaises de vélo
cette expérience permettait de
développer l'autonomie et d'adopter un
comportement citoyen en randonnée il y a
une épreuve de maniabilité donc VTT et
routes il y a eu une épreuve à rallye
donc ils vont faire un parcours de 30 à
40 km il y a une course d'orientation il
y a des questions générales donc c'est
vraiment la tête et les jambes et puis
il y a une épreuve de mécanique pour
l'orientation les jeunes venus de toute
la France devaient retrouver différentes
balises réparties dans la commune sur un
parcours d'environ 3 km et tout ça ça
leur rapporte des points ils ont un
total de 840 à chaque fois qu'ils
trouvent pas de balises ou qui font des
fautes en maniabilité ou dans les
questions ça leur retire des points donc
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un maximum de
points parallèle de cet événement la
Fédération proposait le concours
national d'éducation routière pour 46
listes âgés de 10 à 12 ans objectif
reprendre les bases de la maniabilité et
du code de la route pour améliorer sa
pratique du vélo
QCM slalom est position statique ou
parfois poser les difficultés aux jeunes
sportifs
j'ai pas trop réussi à répondre le
premier atelier les virages serrés parce
que j'ai dû recommencer trois fois c'est
aussi de la convivialité c'est des
régions qui se rencontrent voilà donc
c'est ça et de faire que c'est ces
jeunes là finissent par devenir
adhérents à la Fédération Française de
vélo la Fédération française de
cyclotourisme regroupe environ 100000
membres avec une majorité de licencie
retraités la structure espère rajeunir
sa moyenne d'âge en organisant d'autres
événements cyclistes à destination des
adolescents